estamos en la galería de la colección
phillips en la ciudad de washington
viendo una serie de pinturas de formato
pequeño de jeyko florence es una serie
de 60 pinturas aquí está la mitad y la
otra mitad se encuentra en el museo de
arte moderno el museo de arte moderno
tiene los números pares de la serie y
philips tiene los nones un acuerdo al
que llegó el artista ya que estas
pinturas eran muy cotizadas el artista
era joven cuando realizó estas obras y
es un logro asombroso para un artista
tan joven documentan uno de los eventos
más importantes en la historia de eeuu
la migración de los afroamericanos del
sur agrícola al norte industrial a fines
del siglo 19 y especialmente en la
primera mitad del siglo 20 y lo que
precipitó esto fue no sólo el racismo
extremo y las leyes jim crow de
segregación racial en el sur sino
también porque en el norte las compañías
industriales necesitaban empleados se
calcula que 6 millones de personas se
trasladaron durante estas olas
migratorias y la familia de los reds fue
una de ellas la gente se trasladó a
nueva york como la familia de lawrence y
también a chicago
louis a pittsburgh a todos los centros
industriales la vida en el sur debía
haber sido muy difícil como para que la
gente juntará sus pertenencias y se
mudara con su familia tenían la
esperanza de encontrar una vida mejor en
el norte y en muchos casos así fue pero
también pasaron muchas penurias y
también había racismo en el norte lo
maravilloso de esta serie es que
lawrence capta la complejidad de lo que
pasó con las vidas de estas personas
cuando emigraron lo logran no sólo por
el brillante uso del color
usando tempera sobre madera y una
composición sumamente clara sino también
por los títulos de cada obra casi como
un poema que se abre paso en estas
imágenes cuando vemos estas pinturas
vemos figuras geométricas áreas planas
de color y hay algo sobrio sobre el uso
de las palabras y las imágenes que son
una gran parte de su poder fue muy
meticuloso cuando las produjo había
realizado una investigación exhaustiva
en el centro schönberg en harlem esta
serie en verdad habla del movimiento
habla del cambio el primer panel así
como el último reflejan estaciones de 3
y el movimiento de la gente veamos esta
imagen es una de mis favoritas porque en
verdad se pueden palpar los efectos del
racismo y la discriminación observa esta
cuerda dorada una barrera que separa a
la gente de la derecha y de la izquierda
en este espacio abierto que termina
arriba negándose a usar una perspectiva
lineal dándonos una vista exterior a
vuelo de pájaro el fondo gris es
completamente plano las figuras son
siluetas en tonos oscuros hay una
sensación de aislamiento entre ellas las
de la izquierda los blancos están muy
separadas de aquellas a la derecha la de
hasta arriba está mirando hacia el lado
opuesto de la barrera y se ve bastante
robusto por la forma en que mira hacia
arriba y afuera y el hombre debajo de
esta última está sujetando el periódico
ignorando la mesa dispuesta frente a él
parece estar metido en sus propios
pensamientos pero más que eso por el
tamaño de sus manos parece estar
agarrando el periódico como desafiante
rechazando reconocer a cualquier otro
individuo a su alrededor hay mucha
economía aquí en cuanto a las formas y
las líneas
y a la vez hay tanta expresividad y como
lawrence hace la figura de la parte
superior derecha tan pequeña te da una
sensación de distancia y aislamiento
el artista guía nuestra mirada de arriba
abajo logra que la vista vaya
descendiendo con una dinámica cada vez
mayor es una respuesta de ping pong de
ida y vuelta zincsa guéant es siguiendo
la barrera y a la vez alternando entre
las figuras a ambos lados y si seguimos
esa barrera hacia abajo mira cuánto
podemos decir de la figura del extremo
inferior derecho a partir de esa
economía en las formas podemos decir que
es una figura femenina una mujer mayor
lawrence ha pintado su cabeza más abajo
que sus hombros como si estuviera
recargada sobre la mesa mientras come y
el sombrero que lleva cubre su cabeza
casi completamente es como una campana
es interesante que los únicos que tienen
rasgos faciales son los blancos a los
afroamericanos se les da forma y
personalidad por los contornos de sus
cuerpos siento mucho más compasión por
las figuras de la derecha por los
afroamericanos
de la izquierda aparecen casi
amenazantes lo fascinante de esta obra
es que lores refleja un vocabulario
visual claramente modernista a un tema
que en eeuu expresa la condición de esta
migración moderna de esta
industrialización de este trastorno real
y el vocabulario del modernismo se
refleja en lo plano de las formas la
reducción que vemos pero normalmente
pensamos en el modernismo como una
corriente que no le da importancia al
tema a la narrativa pero aquí la
narrativa está bellamente entretejida
con estas imágenes tan claras